mais tu touches
mais heureusement tu t'es devenu évident
bas
à temps mais tient la plaque d'égout je
suis choqué
du bang c'est une voiture
où je m'arrête tapis rouge
aspérités au feu rouge puis là là je
tourne la tête vers la droite est-ce que
qu'est ce que je vois arrêté au feu
rouge un passé que les arrêtés aux feux
rouges
mais là je te jure le cycliste arrêté au
feu rouge là le mec sans que le feu va
démarrer
descendra comme ça vers la droite il
regarde à droite et regarde à gauche et
là au moment où on ne peut pas sauvayre
et qui voit qu'il peut passer le mec
tourne à droite
en clamant qu'il allait tourner à droite
en regardant à droite au regard de la
gauche vous mur
[Rires]
c'est vraiment
tapé dans l'oeil ça fait longtemps que
ça n'était pas arrivé
il est chaud
l'amant concession peut pas les soirées
comme ça les gens vont vraiment se poser
des questions
l'eau
[Musique]
alors tu manges 3e mois pas de poulet
et donc tu manges pas du tout l'est
pas de poulet
et ben qu'est ce que tu manges à la
place la plus belle place du poulet du
poulet tu dis que tu veux pas du tout
l'air qu'est ce que tu veux à la place
c'est pas compliqué ce que je demande
mais s'il fait du poulet je veux pas
poulet
non tu viens de me dire pas tu voulais
du pad poulet c'est compliqué ou pas